malgré son climat rigoureux et son
éloignement la suède paradis de
l'égalité de la justice sociale attire
année après année un nombre record de
migrants ici un habitant sur 100 est un
demandeur d'asile
c'est dans le fin fond d'une campagne à
trois heures de route de la capitale
stockholm que nous sommes allés
rencontrer une de ces familles réfugiées
une famille pas comme les autres forst
main dessus
au début la souffrance se disait sur son
visage aux fesses coast and 18 ans et sa
soeur milena 13 ans sont les deux
enfants est né d'une famille arménienne
venu ici de moscou ils ne sont pas
justes en dormi ils sont dans un état
comateux depuis deux ans et demi pour
l'un et presque deux ans pour l'autre
c'est impossible d'ouvrir la bouche car
les muscles sont trop contractés
il ne bouge pas ne parle pas n'ouvre pas
les yeux ne dessert pas les dents leurs
parents les nourrices cinq fois par jour
à l'aide d'une sonde qui passe par le
nez jusqu'à l'estomac leur condition
s'appelle le syndrome de la résignation
une très très grande part un très très
grand stress qui va faire en sorte que
toute la mobilisation du corps qui
devrait être là pour nous aider à
survivre voire tout simplement tombé à
zéro si vous voulez et là on refaire le
membre bien que les origines du
phénomène soit mal connu l'apparition du
syndrome suis à peu près toujours la
même trajectoire
mais ce qu'on sait c'est que ça commence
par une dépression non comme une
symptomatologie qui apparaît dépressive
et tranquillement pouvait-on va aller
vers ce seuil monde donc une espèce de
perte de conscience et ensuite on va se
retrouver devant un comportement
catatonique comme ça où il ya plus
aucune fonction risbo aux eisa et hino
il est dans cet état depuis que je viens
ici chaque fois qu'elle vient ici la
docteur elisabeth woods crâne ce fait
les mêmes examens
la conclusion est toujours là même pas
d'atteinte neurologique un état de
stupeur profond qui fait que ces
adolescents le réagissent à aucun
stimuli il ne réagit même pas avec un
sac gelé sur le ventre à -18 degrés
celsius
exact la pression reste la même depuis
que cette spécialiste en orl a pris sa
retraite il ya quelques années elle
s'est occupé bénévolement d'une
cinquantaine d'enfants atteints du
syndrome de résignation docteur could
cry connais chaque histoire parker elle
a vu la jeune mylène a sombré dans cet
état en voyant ce qui arrivait à son
frère aîné c'est windows live mail voir
l'état de son frère se dégrader l'a
affecté rivaux ce big blindes et des
peuples est l'étoile et sade chez
becquet me wael a pris conscience que sa
famille ne pouvait rester et sa
condition a commencé à se détériorer
so have that she would turn in the shell
ouais
selon elle pratiquement tous ses enfants
ont une histoire de vie particulièrement
dramatique
sokol le traumatisme commence dans le
pays d'origine
ils appartiennent souvent à une minorité
ethnique opprimés et les oppresseurs ont
craqué c'est exactement la situation de
la famille de castanet milena avenue de
moscow arménien ils disent avoir été
victimes d'attaqués racistes pendant des
années ils ont attaqué mon mari j'ai
juste eu le temps de prendre les enfants
et de m'enfuir
une fois les enfants à la maison je suis
revenu et j'ai trouvé mon avis
inconscient il est resté à l'hôpital une
semaine nous étions terrorisés
les attaques verbales notamment contre
les enfants à l'école était leur
quotidien à moscou josh otage l'une des
causes et la ferveur nationaliste et
religieuse du temps de l'union
soviétique
ça n'existait pas et pour cette famille
l'espoir d'une vie meilleure et plus
sécuritaires en suède s'est transformé
en cauchemar
ce pays autrefois parmi les plus ouverts
aux réfugiés a décidé de fermer ses
portes l'automne dernier la famille a
reçu un premier refus
elle est maintenant menacée d'expulsion
rochester haute corse
les autorités nous disent que malgré la
condition physique de nos enfants ils
peuvent nous expulser mais dans quel
pays est vicié cop 9 mois le nil tarbes
à pied d'oeuvre depuis le début des
années 2000 on a diagnostiqué le
syndrome de résignation chez plusieurs
centaines d'enfants réfugiés en suède et
de nombreuses théories ont circulé sur
son mécanisme
on a même soupçonné la simulation je ne
connais aucun enfant de 8 ans qui
pourrait négocier le fait de ces sites
alimentés pendant deux ans et demi c'est
presque impossible
le deuxième ils ne réagissent pas à la
douleur et ce bond à la douleur c'est
pas quelque chose qu'on peut simuler de
pour réagir à la douleur leur situation
semble désespérée pourtant qu'au scanner
milena pourrait en sortir
la condition première que la suède leur
accorde la résidence on l'a vu dans des
centaines de cas d'enfants avant eux et
alex lippi
ils sont comme la belle au bois dormant
elle est blanche neige endormi si elle
se sent en sécurité et reçoit de l'amour
elle se réveillera il n'y a qu'un
médicament possible pour ces enfants
l'oeil ça s'appelle la restauration de
l'espoir
alors voici le médicament que ça
fonctionne car ces enfants ne peuvent
avoir un espoir qui est restaurée ils
vont sortir de leur mutisme ce qui
suggère qu'ils entendent
en attendant aucun signe d'espoir du
côté des autorités
la famille craint le pire et le plus
jeune des enfants et h à 11 ans commence
à présenter des symptômes
deux dépressions
[Musique]